late in the first half there were some
strange going-ons at miami where the san
francisco 49ers were not using their
timeouts john lynch gm of the team
what's going on use your timeouts and
that was the first moment in the game
where there was any criticism
of coach kyle shanahan but it got worse
in the second half and look chris we
talked earlier about the decision fourth
and two first drive of the third quarter
at the 24 yard line of the cheese
kicking the field goal making it 13 to
10. you and i are fine with that what
we're not fine with or at least what i'm
not fine with is the clock management
with the ball 11 57 to play up 10 points
against an offense that has the
potential to emerge from its slumber at
any given moment you've got to chew the
clock you've got to run the ball this is
the ultimate running machine tyron
matthews the chief safety said after the
game we were grateful when they stopped
running the ball you get five yards on
first down and then you throw a couple
of passes and you have to punt they did
that when they got the ball back up
three throwing the ball and not running
the clock when they should that's the
criticism here chris you've got to keep
the clock moving you've got to give a
coach in andy reid who's got a
reputation for not displaying a sense of
urgency with a game on the line you got
to give him less time on the clock not
more well yeah yeah okay yes i
understand that you know it wasn't like
he was calling bombs down the field or
anything like that you know we're also
we could also be sitting here you know
and again the play we're talking about
the guy behind was open it was right
over the middle of the field it wasn't a
like a a huge risky play throw what you
had was a great player and chris jones
who just read the drop of the
quarterback and spiked the ball down you
know but i'm not gonna sit here and just
go oh my gosh my buddy kyle shanahan
really botched the super bowl with his
clock management i don't look at it that
way i think if they win the game we're
going look this is what you have to do
if you want to kill the beast and
patrick mahomes and what they do you got
to be aggressive you can't run the
football
you know so that's but but they but they
are aggressive by running the football
see that's the thing when you go six
quarters of this machine that just
churns and churns like they were
churning and churning in the third
quarter on that first drive like we saw
them on a couple of drives in the first
half churning and churning why do you
abandon that and take the chance that
your quarterback is going to miss guys
that that he's going to show something
that chris jones is going to read
reminding me the end of the seahawks
game on monday night when they left too
much time for the seahawks because jimmy
garoppolo didn't complete the passes
that were dialed up for him you know you
have to account for the fact that jimmy
garoppolo isn't patrick mahomes isn't
tom brady isn't a short-list franchise
quarterback when you're selecting those
plays late in the game when you're
trying to either build on a lead hold a
lead or a little bit of both well yeah
listen i yes jimmy garoppolo is not
patrick mahomes we talked about this
ken kansas you know we talked about this
all week can kansas city get san
francisco into a game where he's got to
throw the ball and make those plays and
we know that's not their bread and
butter but i'm still you know again you
know i i everyone's acting like this was
like a steamroll session that the 49ers
were just running the ball at 10 yards a
clip they weren't let's look at the
stats you know the biggest runs of the
day were these game plan toss up your
type plays with debo samuel on the edge
they weren't dominating the line of
scrimmage the way they were just gonna
go we're gonna smash it up the middle
for six yards every play it wasn't that
type of game so i understand everybody's
gonna sit back and go oh man kyle
shanahan another fourth quarter blown
lead first off the first one's on dan
quinn dan quinn's fault in atlanta not
kyle shannon and i'll say this there's
been three right three ten point fourth
quarter blown leads here right it's the
patriots at super bowl 49 the falcons in
super bowl 51 and then yesterday you
know what i look at that's in common if
i'm gonna blame my buddy kyle shanahan
for anything
all three are the seattle defensive
scheme mike the scheme that i tell you
all the time they line up in the same
defense every single play and it's all
about the pass rush and if the pass rush
doesn't get there the quarterback feels
very comfortable because it's the same
defense wait wait wait wait for it
every single play and that's one of my
that if i'm gonna bust on my buddy kyle
shannon for anything it's the damn
seattle defensive scheme but i'm not
gonna get mad at him for trying to throw
a five-yard pass over the middle where a
great player just made a great play
i got my drive screwed up the drive with
11 50 yeah you're talking about it yeah
it started off well right they gained 18
yards and two plays now one was a throw
yes but then after that that's when it
started to fall apart they had a first
ten run right for one yard and then he
decided to throw the ball it was
incomplete and then joe staley jumped
off sides i know i was going to correct
you but your point was still real i got
you and when and when jimmy garoppolo
ran to the sideline he got shoved out of
bounds man that that i was sitting kind
of far away from that but that if that
flag comes out it might be the flag
comes out we're talking about the 49ers
as champions today right yes i mean that
was that was close there was a there was
a few moments between kansas city doing
that
and dancing around not getting a first
down a few times after some completions
by tyree kill and and travis kelsey
where i went what are you guys doing but
you're right that was dangerously close
mike
but when they got the ball back up three
606 to play
rahim mostly gains five yards on first
down and that's when the two passes came
after that and you get the ball at 606
you give it back to the chiefs at 5 18.
down three points you're asking to lose
and that's exactly what happened the
chief scored their second touchdown then
they scored their third and then the
lights were out yeah the lights were out
yeah i mean you know yeah they found
their mojo with that third and 15 and
that got them rolling and then we just
saw mahomes magic
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports